why is moderation so hard to achieve why
can't humans just ever get enough it
never made sense until maybe I don't
know the 1970s to start moderating right
we're we're species that came up in
these environments where everything we
needed to survive was scarce food stuff
information even number of people we
could influence status things like that
um and so the people who lived on and
spread their DNA were people who tended
to not try and moderate on those things
right but the difference is that today
we have an abundance of all these things
that we're sort of built to Crave if you
will and um we still have our old our
old genes that push us into more so
because we existed for almost all of
human history with less than we wanted
less than we needed we have seen
everything as being a fleeting brief
amount of abundance in an ocean of
scarcity we should take it advantage of
it right now give me more more more of
everything that's in front yeah exactly
right in the and take food food's a
great example in the past it was hard to
find food you would have to walk around
all day pick it out of the ground pick
it off a tree you would have to hunt it
have to literally run it down until it
was exhausted and then you'd spear it
and then youd take it home and so it
required effort and there was never a
maximal amount of it so when you had the
opportunity to eat you wanted to eat as
much as possible
and you even still see this today in
some tribes where I talked to a a
researcher who was hanging out I think
with the a tribe in Paraguay and he's
like these guys Came Upon This orange
Bush and they literally ate oranges
until they threw up and then they ate
more oranges right because that sort of
behavior gave you a survival advantage
in the past because you would put on
that those extra calories as as fat and
in the times when you inevitably
encountered a scarcity and you were
starting to lose weight uh you would
have something to draw on we still have
that exact same Drive in a world where
now that you live in the US you can
identify with this where there's a
7-Eleven on every corner pumping out
cocacola and Slurpees and bags of food
and we've got you know I live in Vegas
there's buffets where people will go up
you know 10 times and uh that often
backfires but it's not just of course
it's not just food right it's all these
other things it's like the average
person today owns more than 10,000 items
the house right we see more information
some researchers think in one day than
the average person 700 years ago would
have seen in their entire
life and so it's all these different
things that used to give us a survival
Advantage overdoing them we now have an
abundance of them and continue to overdo
them do you ever think about the fact
that the selection press pressures on
our ancestors and the uh fulfillment
pressures on us now have basically inv
converted so we are the progyny of the
people who would have sought out more
information who would have sought out
more food who would have sought out more
status or Identity or certainty or
whatever it is and we are uh inheriting
the challenge that they benefited from
in a world now that is terribly
mismatched yeah exactly that's exactly
it and you know I will say like let me
be clear these are good problems we have
now
like I'll take having to try to not eat
too much rather than being like where's
my next meal are we going to survive
this upcoming bad winter right but
there's still problems nonetheless and
so a lot of what the book does is it
looks at how did we get here um what in
particular is pushing us into more today
because I think what's also interesting
about the last you know since the 1980s
is that I think that technology has
really allowed um insights into what
really drives people and hooks people on
behaviors that push them into more so as
part of the book for example I uh well
I'll just I'll just build this up by
saying we have technology that really is
pushing us into more and one of the
insights of This Book Is that I sort of
discovered what I call the scarcity Loop
now this is a three-part Behavior Loop
that
is
unparalleled at pushing people out of
moderation it is the serial killer of
moderation now the way that I discovered
this is that I live in Las Vegas and
living in Las Vegas you see a lot of
weird stuff right I mean it is a town
built on excess and getting people to
eat more to spend more to do more to
have more fun to do all these things to
access but by far the best thing and the
weirdest thing is the slot machines
because these things are are freaking
everywhere and people play them around
the clock I mean they're in grocery
stores they're in gas stations they're
in restaurants
and I wonder why do people sit here and
play these things for hours and hours
because this is an inherently irrational
Behavior The House Always Wins everyone
knows this so why are you hooked on this
behavior that doesn't make any damn
sense it
doesn't so this leads me to start asking
questions long story short I end up at
this casino on the edge of town in Las
Vegas it's one of the newest casinos in
town super Cutting Edge uh but the
public isn't welcome and that's because
it's a casino laboratory so the gambling
industry as well as a bunch of big tech
companies uh basically built a real
casino but it is a human behavior
laboratory and so they're looking at all
these different ways that what happens
in a casino impacts human
behavior now as part of this visit I end
up to bring it back to slot machines you
probably wonder why the hell is this guy
talking about slot machines um I end up
talking to a slot machine engineer and
he walks me through through why slot
machines are so effective and they run
on this Loop that I call the scarcity
Loop and it's got three parts so it's
got opportunity unpredictable rewards
and quick repeatability so opportunity
you have an opportunity to get something
of value in the case of a slot machine
it's money uh two unpredictable rewards
you know you'll get that thing of value
eventually but you don't know when and
you don't know how valuable it's going
to be so with a slot machine you play a
game you could lose your money you could
win a dollar you could win a million
dollars and there's a fantastic range of
outcomes and they're all unpredictable
and then three quick repeatability you
can repeat the behavior immediately so
with the case of slot machines the
average slot machine player plays 16
games in a minute which is about as much
as we blink now the important part and
why uh I'm not telling you just about
slot machines to tell you about slot
machines is that this system is inherent
in tons of the Technologies and even
institutions that I think most influence
our life today so what is what makes
social media work it has been embedded
in a lot of personal finance apps like
Robin Hood it's part of the rise of
sports betting obviously it is what
makes dating apps so enthralling it's in
our education it's in our food system
and on and on and on you start you know
when I started really looking at this
thing you're like oh wow this is
everywhere and it is such an important
part of so many behaviors that people do
over and over and over eventually to
their detriment to some degree or
another so I it's really great and I
love using gambling as an analogy uh
some of the cool stuff that you can
learn about uh there's no right angles
on the carpet if you walk into a uh a
casino there's never windows to the
outside world uh there's rumors that
they increase the oxygen saturation in
the air uh by pushing this stuff through
um so all of that fascinating the same
number of times that you blink is the
same number of times that you play slot
machines also fascinating what I don't
get yet is why why have you called this
the scarcity loop I don't this there
doesn't seem to be any scarcity in in
this what am I missing well it pushes us
into more and I will say so when I
started um trying to unpack why slot
machines work the first thing I did is I
called a bunch of researchers who uh
basically research gambling but from a
here's why gambling is bad perspective
and they told me all these reasons why
people supposedly to gamble to excess
and it was what you said it's there's no
right angles in casinos it's that slot
machines play in the key of C which is
supposed to be relaxing and so we're
going to spend more they don't have
clocks and the problem with that is that
when you go into a casino you see right
angles everywhere I mean the I mean this
the slot machine screens are a right
angle it's a box so that doesn't make
any sense I call up a slot machine audio
composer I go hey like what do you what
do you use when you write these little
slot Jingles that's a real job you can
have in Las Vegas by the way it's a good
town uh he goes no where the hell did
you hear that he's like I use all
different keys and then the clocks thing
is like yeah casinos don't have clocks
but neither does like Walmart or Target
or Costco or your grocery store it's not
normal to just hang clocks everywhere in
a business right and really what makes
people gamble is that this Loop that I
told you about the scarcity Loop is that
it's inh
enthralling to humans it's the
definition of what makes a interesting
game and it can provide a fun
escape right so even though there isn't
a scarcity it pushes us Beyond
moderation which is the situation that
we would have done had there have been a
scarcity okay that makes sense okay so
why are we so hooked by this like what
is it that it's doing to us that's
causing us to stay on and on and on yeah
so I called a guy whose name is Thomas
zental now this guy is in his 80s he
started studying psychology in I think
1968 is when he graduated got his PhD
from UC Berkeley and he was following up
on a lot of research behavioral research
like he's a you know sort of direct
descendant of of Skinner and
um when psychologist started realizing
that animals get really hooked on
unpredictable Rewards
Skinner had been um feeding rats treats
at a predictable interval and he started
running out of treats and so what he
ends up doing long story short is he
goes okay I don't want to make more
treats it's going to take a lot of time
I'm just going to give these Rats the
treats unpredictably like I'll just give
them every now and then and they're
probably going to get bored they're
going to get bumped out they're going to
you know whatever and what he found is
the opposite happened these rats got
totally uh enthralled in hitting this
lever if they didn't know when they were
going to get a tree so zal he goes okay
I'm going to follow up on this because
this is weird and this guy has basically
found that it's pretty easy to turn a
pigeon into a degenerate Gambler he
gives these studies where he has pigeons
can play one game where it's a
predictable reward game or they can play
another game where it's an unpredictable
reward game so it's very much like a
slot machine setup now in the
unpredictable reward game they will get
less food overall for the behavior and
what he found is that 97% of pigeons
choose the unpredictable reward game
they choose to gamble rather than play
the game that gets them more food
overall this like doesn't make any damn
sense right and what he told me is he
thinks that this Behavior the fact that
we do tend to really hone in and focus
on unpredictable rewards probably tracks
back to finding food so if you think
about humans you know hundreds of
thousands of years ago we have to find
food every day and we don't necessarily
know where that food is so you go to one
place no food
you go to another place no food you go
to another place no food you go to
another place oh my God jackpot there's
so much food right so our brain seems to
incentivize this sort of repeat search
for something and get excited when it
happens the center of the bullseye
according to both Sam Harris and Andrew
huberman when it comes to pleasure is
things being about to be slightly better
than we done
anticipated yeah like that just it's the
very beginning of the moment when
something good happens it's when you you
turn on Instagram and there's a hundred
new
comments it's when you are just about to
head out a really good study from uh my
old industry of nightlife they got
people to track uh they pinged them on
their phone and got them to track the uh
level of happiness that they had
throughout the entire night right from
like 3 in the afternoon till 3: in the
morning and you'd think you're going to
go on this night out and there's going
to be a DJ and there's going to be music
and you're going to be drunk and all of
this stuff but it wasn't the time when
people were the most happy was when they
were getting ready with their friends
before they went out so anticipation is
the bullseye of happiness and it's one
of the reasons for the fledgling
marketers out there a really protracted
launch sequence of anything that you're
going to do drag it out make it [__]
excruciatingly painful because in my
opinion
people like to have things that they
look forward to and you can be that
thing right just add another thing to
the calendar it's like oh and there's
the the new Michael Easter substack post
that he's been working on for six months
like I'm excit he's been talking about
this for weeks I'm really really excited
about this like that is the bullseye of
Happiness yeah totally and you know the
huberman and the the Sam Harris they're
absolutely spot on another good person
to ask is someone who's made a shitload
of money using that and that would be
the gambling industry and and the slot
slot designer I talked to said yeah
gambling isn't when you know whether you
won or loss it's when the dice are
rolling across the table it's when the
reels are still spinning it's when the
cards are falling and you're figuring
out is it going to be good is it going
to be bad is it going to be really
really good that's it it's the whole
deal and to your point I mean that is
that is why that's embedded in so many
systems that um are effective at
grabbing people's attention today take
dating apps right you swipe you swipe
you swipe and you go oh I got a match is
it the person who I was like I don't
know if I'll swipe on this one or was it
the person I'm like oh my God that's the
most amazing human being I've ever seen
in my life right that's what's exciting
about these things and it I mean I I
really do feel like so much of the world
has effectively started leaning into
these sort of slot machine gambling
mechanics and it's no damn wonder why
you see people spending on average 12 to
13 hours a day engag with digital media
of course not all of it is spent on
Instagram but you look at people's
screen time and like a lot of Instagram
a lot of Tik Tok a lot of email too like
even um Tristan Harris who's the very
you know silicon like kind of anti-icon
Valley guy I mean even he admits to
getting fixed on email because it's
totally random word you like Ping is it
a uh is it an advertisement from Nike
with new more shoes or is it like oh I
just got in you know for him oh it's an
interview request from 60 minutes or
whatever it might be yeah where does the
scarcity Loop
live what was that where does the
scarcity Loop live where yeah I mean so
social media it's in email I also think
it's part of the news cycle you start to
see unpredictability to really rise
after uh basically 2016 with Trump and
now you're seeing it even more embedded
into news with you know breaking news
becoming a thing uh I mentioned dating
apps I mentioned personal finance apps
like Robin Hood so for example Robin
Hood what really made that app take off
is that they leveraged quick
repeatability so before Robin Hood uh
you would have to pay to make a trade so
that slows down the rate of trading
Robin Hood what they did is they
leverage this uh concept called payment
order flow where it makes it um the
trading fees are basically baked in so
you can make quick repeat trades
throughout the day and you see that app
just take off and they even had
basically gambling mechanics to get
people in where you'd spin a wheel uh
Regulators actually made them take take
that down because they're like no this
is just way too Casino like
um got a fly in the room that's how it
goes uh it's in advertising so for
example uh a lot of a lot of companies
are using Casino like features for ads
so you go on websites now you might have
to spend a wheel to get a bargain and
that increases uh conversion rates by
Sevenfold According to some research
Sevenfold so if you just get someone to
spin a wheel and they're like oh my God
I won 30% off holy [__] they're more
likely to buy uh it's in shopping online
shopping I mean think of something like
Lightning Deals that's quick
repeatability that's lending on uh
scarcity and
urgency temu teu TAMU are you familiar
with this site no what's that okay it is
uh I would compare it to the crystal
methamphetamine of shopping wow so it is
um you go on and it's basically we have
a limited amount there's a limited
amount of time to get a bargain and
right when you pop on there's a wheel
you spin for a bargain it's a it
basically sells stuff direct from
factories in China and um they've just
turned the whole site into a casino of
Bargains so it's pretty crazy wow okay
so talk to me about how humans like to
escape and how this plays a
role yeah so when you think about Escape
it's essentially a removal from the
complexities and problems of everyday
life and these sorts of systems with the
scarcity Loop tend to be a great uh
Escape because you can fall into the
system and you can repeat this
effectively what is a game uh and your
problems tend to dissolve when you're in
this and and what really happens when
you think about a traditional game is
that traditional games sort of give us
some obstacles some unpredictability
more or less uh in exchange for knowing
that we did exactly the right thing so
at the end of the game you know whether
you won or lost right and that seems to
be sort of calming and relaxing for
humans but the problem with the scarcity
Loop is that because it is such a Escape
such a great system for a game if you do
it too often it can be quite bad but at
the same time if you're just doing it
every now and then I mean it's it's
totally fine so I don't want the message
of people to walk away from reading this
book going like oh I need to never do
anything that falls into this loop it's
like no that's not it uh because it is
fun like I like to gamble gambling's fun
the problem is is if I decide oh I want
to gamble all the time now we start to
really have a problem and people tend to
get hooked on the system and such a way
that allows them to escape in a way that
hurts them in the long run is there a an
element of Flow State
here yeah there I mean there could be it
sounds to me hearing you talk about it
and saying you know there's there's sort
of a there's an interaction that you
kind of Lose Yourself I imagine the
people that play Slots that time kind of
does dissolve for them that they almost
become one uh I don't think that there's
a massive amount of skill associated
with slots but for the people that find
themselves in flow their um skill
requirement and skill level are often
only a little bit apart in any case so
perhaps even though it's low
uh skill requirement the skill level of
the participants is uh matched
appropriately so yeah I just I figured
that um I've got ran Doris coming on
soon from flow research Collective I'm
going to ask him about um whether there
is flow found in compulsive behaviors
like Tik Tok and uh gambling and I'm I'm
pretty sure that he's going to say
you're going to drop into Thea or Delta
when it comes to brain waves it's going
to be kind of oddly agitating and
relaxing at the same time to do this
stuff think about the way that you feel
while you're on social media it's it's
very compulsive it it is kind of
relaxing and passive and it's also kind
of agitating and [__] does your head
in so it's like a right a balance
between the two well it's the it's the
sort of Randomness between is this post
G to be agitating or is it g to make me
laugh my ass off is it g to make me you
know is it going to be some video where
the soldier comes home and the dog runs
at the soldier and I just start crying
Hyster
my favorite videos yeah so I do think
that there is an element of where people
do zone out and what's what's
interesting is when um researchers talk
to like seriously compulsive slot
machine players they actually get
annoyed when they win a lot of money
because it interrupts the process
because when you win a lot of money on a
slot machine it goes ballistic and it um
if you win more than $ thousand dollars
you have to pay taxes on it so it shuts
off the machine and they have to come
give you a payment by hand and that down
what they're actually there for which is
just to Simply write out this sort of
process of kind of you know maybe you're
up maybe you're down sometimes what's
the story of
captagon oh yeah so uh captagon is this
drug that was not super well known I
would say even just a handful of years
ago and it's now effectively sort of
overtaken the Middle East where there
are billions of pills circulating
throughout the middle Middle East in
particular it uh started in the 60s as a
drug to treat uh ADHD and depression and
in the 70s uh psychiatrists realized
that it worked a little too well so they
uh they ban it and there had developed
sort of this uh a lot of fans of it
let's say in Middle Eastern countries
because um it's a it's effectively an
amphetamine it's like a lowgrade uh meth
you can think about it as and um
so you had some gangs in I think
Bulgaria gang up and start supplying the
Middle
East and then the [__] fly
is this is the best
dude I would be annoyed if it weren't so
damn funny right um if he comes back
just hit yourself in the head really
really hard yeah dude I'm just going to
bang yeah um Hungarian Middle East
yeah so there was these gangs in
Bulgaria that start Sor to the
hungarians Y and um but eventually what
happened is
that Syria started producing it so
especially after the fall of Syria um
it's now produced in government labs and
the production of captagon is actually
far greater in Syria uh or greater than
legal exports in Syria and they're
effectively supplying the Middle East
with this drug Capon there was just a
there was just a finding just like a
week ago where they busted about a
billion dollars worth of pills at uh a
port coming into the Middle East so long
story short is that I traveled to Iraq
to sort of understand this problem and
effectively about addiction because when
you think about
overusing this scarcity Loop it really
can become an addiction now to me
addiction is a behavior that you uh
consistently repeat and provide you a
benefit in the short ter term while
giving long-term benefits effectively or
long-term detriments right now Iraq is
interesting because it's a country where
addiction effectively didn't exist for a
very long time and that's just because
Saddam ruled with an Iron Fist and once
Iraq Falls after uh the US invades it
what happens is you have a lot of people
who have a lot of problems and Trauma
right from that war and then Syria Falls
and you get this massive uh supply of
Capon and it starts moving its way
throughout the Middle East and into Iraq
and you start to see a huge uptick in
addiction to this drug and so I think it
stands for sort of this greater question
about addiction which the US government
has typically seen it uh two ways for a
long time it was seen as a moral failing
right so an addict was a bad person or
just a person who's making their bad
choices like damn it let's throw them in
jail in the mid 90s you start to see
addiction positioned as a brain disease
now the reason that this positioning
occurred is because neuroscience and
brain scans were becoming pretty popular
at the time and when neuroscientists
would do um scans on addict's brains
they saw that their liking system of
their brain which is basically the
system that we think is actually the
sort of pleasure Center it would not
have any activity but their brain would
still pump out high levels of dopamine
Drive making them want a drug right so
we see this strange mismatch and like
wow this thing doesn't light up but this
thing does light up so they start to
argue that it's a brain disease it's
just caused by this you know sort of
mismatch and brain chemicals and on and
on and
on and I think to me after really
looking into this I see addiction as
more more of a symptom typically of
something
larger so to me addiction uh you need a
few things you need a you need a
population or a person who has uh
problems you need a substance that can
relieve the problems and the person has
to have uh no other means of fixing the
problems Beyond this substance and I
think Iraq um sort of knows that and you
also tend to see this idea in research
where you know the naida which is the
National Institute on drug abuse they
argue that addiction is basically you
can't get over it it's this compulsive
recurring disease uh that is in the
brain and so once you're addicted you're
pretty much addicted and you're not
going to have a high chance of recovery
but you look at uh examples like in the
70s there was Operation golden flow
which is is with uh soldiers in Vietnam
where something like 25% of soldiers US
soldiers who were fighting in Vietnam
were addicted to heroin and Nixon was
like yeah I don't want these heroin
addicts coming back into the United
States like if you want to come back in
the United States you got to give us a
clean urine
test so if addiction is something that
is near impossible to get over and it's
this brain disease that you can't fix
and you have zero at all agency in you
would think we would have left 25% of
soldiers in Vietnam but the reality of
what happened is that the vast majority
of these soldiers all produced clean
urine they all made it back home and
once they were back
home very very few of them relapsed and
the ones who did Relapse relapse tended
to have been using drugs before they got
to
Vietnam so I think that it shows that uh
addiction is a lot more complex than
just the person is a bad person the
person has this brain disease that has
you know nothing to do with behavior and
conditions and environment and all this
other things so that chapter of the book
uh really looks into those questions
this sort of changing ideas around
addiction yeah it's a strange one man um
you know to think about kind of soft
addictions too uh not somebody who is an
alcoholic but every evening after they
get home from a difficult job maybe
their relationship or family situation
isn't fantastic maybe they're stressed
about one or a few things it's just you
know it's it's five points and then I
can go to sleep or the person that
always uses weeds to wind down on an
evening time the line between you know a
compulsion a dependency an addiction it
all kind of becomes very blurred I like
the fact that you say um it's somebody
who has a problem and the solution that
they reach for is this particular
substance or or or or stimulus um I
think that's a nice way to look at it I
mean you I know people
who if they're emotionally upset they'll
go on their phone like their phone is
the distraction from whatever emotions
that they're feeling
right yeah uh yeah these things all
provide a sort of escape from problems
is the is the underlying theme and you
know to me me people will look at a drug
addict and go that doesn't make any
sense just like I was with the uh with
the slot machine players but the reality
is is that and I can speak about this
because I'm a person who is nine years
sober now going on 10 nothing fixes a
problem like using a substance at least
in the short
term so this is this might seem like an
IR like if you're an alcoholic it might
seem totally irrational to take a drink
it's not at least in the short term the
problem is that your fixing a problem in
the short term but you're creating
long-term problems for yourself so
addiction wouldn't be a problem if a
person like me goes you know what I'm
GNA have like 10 beers and I'm G to go
volunteer and I'm going to go donate my
time and my money and I'm going to do
all these good things for society now
the problem is that what tends to happen
is that when people sort of zone out
like that they tend to do behaviors uh
that hurt not just them but Society in
the Long Haul is it possible to come
dependent on certainty do you
think yeah I think so I mean look at uh
this is this might be a strange example
but look what happens when people think
they have um you know you get a pain in
your side and people are like what is
that and then you go on you know
whatever it is web andd and people will
obsess ptis that's it pendy no it's not
that's not it man it's stage four cancer
actually you know and so people are just
going down the rabbit hole the rabbit
hole of trying to find answers to
questions that are inherent so much of
life is uncertain and so much of the uh
the sort of data that we use I think
also has uncertainty baked into it
because it's based on human judgments at
the end of the day it's like what are
you going to do with this data what does
it mean and um oh soang hang on do you
think that hypochondriacs are dependent
on certainty in some
way yeah well they don't they hate
unpredictability that's for sure yeah
they could they they abhor an open loop
right so what a hypochondriac by this
framing maybe here comes some bro signs
uh by this framing a
hypochondriac hypochondria act would
sooner have an assumption that's
fatal than an open loop that allows them
to
survive yeah I could see that I mean
certainty feels
good right there's a part in the book
where I talk about you know why why do
people love certainty so much and it
seemed to be you know it's possible this
is a theorizing from a philosopher I
talked to is at the U University of Utah
his name's uh twin it's t h i n ye n he
talked about how probably as humans
evolved we could trust certainty this
aha feeling we'd get that we'd solved
this problem right because if you're
looking for food you can be rather
certain that like you've you found the
food you know that you escaped the tiger
or whatever um but I think today the
questions that we grapple with are much
more complex but we still love this aha
feeling except we we have a million
different answers we could find for for
a question right if you ask are carbs
good or bad you could type that into
Google and it's like oh they're bad aha
I got it yeah there's a governmental
conspiracy around sugar or you could
find another thing that's oh carbs are
good yeah there's this uh there's this
group that all they eat is carbs and
like they live to 110 right so I think
that we live in a world now where you
can very easily maybe reinforce a
pre-existing belief or at least find
information that makes you feel certain
about questions that are inherently
always going to be uncertain because so
much so many questions are are
individual and it's like you know pick
an answer what are you going to do we're
never going to know yeah I've had the
theory for a little while about how the
modern information landscape isn't
trying to convince the populace of any
one narrative but to try and make them
unconvinced about all narratives you
know if you were to create an
information landscape at the moment to
just cause Mass distrust of yourself of
the world around you of even your
neighbor uh that that's what you would
do I'm like the least conspiratorial
person on the planet
but whether it's by
coordination or
[Music]
um like
coincidence the end result is people not
being sure what to believe am I supposed
to eat meat is meat killing me or is it
not should I go vegan Rich R says that I
should go vegan but Stan eing says that
I should go what about Mela Peterson she
seems to be she's lost loads of weight
she looks good like there is a myriad of
solutions to exactly the same problem
coming in opposite directions
and is Ukraine are Ukraine the good guys
or Russia the good guys is Russell Brand
guilty of doing something heinous or is
this a coordinated attack because big
farmer are scared about him getting too
close like for every cultural movement
there is a countercultural movement
here's like this there's a prediction
that you can
make with almost certainty that if you
want to work out what's going to happen
within the next six months look at a
cultural movement that's been born out
that as yet hasn't had its inverse uh
made popular so if you have mgtown men
going their own way in the dating Market
I'm exiting the dating market for every
mgtow you're going to find a red pill
right so for the guys that are exiting
that are the guys that are leaning in
for the Trad wives the girls that are
going to kind of regress back to this
sort of 60s aesthetic for partners
there's going to be the boss [__]
right for every incel there's going to
be a pickup artist for every Sigma grind
set Bro leaning in there's going to be
the spiritual bro that's kind of leaning
out right aism and Hedonism you know
whatever's going on [__] uh Megan the
stallion 2021 summer 2021 hot girls
summer 2022 feral girl summer right
right every cultural movement has the
inverse about to happen because what it
creates is essentially a vacuum that you
can position yourself against somebody
else and this is how the information
landscape at large works I think yeah I
think so and I I mean this is largely
product of the internet I had I had this
strange we're doing bro philosophy again
here um last night I'm for whatever
reason I was thinking about what the
world of Fitness used to be like and
what people would get interested in and
do you remember when there was those
videos I think the videos were called
like
P90x and the whole thing the whole thing
was you know what the benefit is it's
muscle confusion that was their whole
thing and people were like this is
before the internet so people go
oh muscle confusion yeah that that makes
sense I've never heard that that makes
sense your muscles are confused so they
just like they go crazy and they grow
now everyone has an internet connection
you I mean you could literally just type
in muscle confusion and you would get a
thousand hits for like oh here's P90X as
it works here this here's this person
saying like here's why it could
theoretically work here's this other
smart person going no that doesn't make
any damn sense at all right so people
can fact check more easily today you
don't just take what's sort of given to
you but at the same time the
factchecking process if you don't know
where to find good facts then you're not
really factchecking right and you could
argue like who the hell knows what is
actually true it's like no one really
knows right we have to make this kind of
strange decision where we go back to
what you were talking about with
nutrition it's like who am I going to
trust and then the question is okay well
why are you trusting that person and you
can like provide some rationale but
really I don't think you could truly
unpack like well why do I trust this
person right like how did you end up
trusting this person I don't know right
and so it's it's it's definitely a
strange landscape I mean you know I have
certain people that I'm like yeah I'm
pretty sure this person is right but at
the same time I think we live in a world
where it makes sense to to be open to
the possibilities and know that science
is always is always changing science is
a process um people will sound very
smart and great because they're pulling
from science but at the end of the day
that science might change and we also
need to be okay with that that doesn't
make the person wrong that just means
that they're they might be following the
scientific process and so it it is a
time where I I don't think you can be
certain about a lot of things and yet we
really want that certainty and I think
that that can lead to um frustrations or
at least it's like why why do people go
down in foxholes when the fox holes are
constantly changing right so yeah well
you'll be familiar with the zygon effect
I'm guessing no tell me about
okay so um this
psychologist Mr zonic was doing a study
on servers in restaurants and if you've
ever had a server come up to you and
stand there and ask for your order and
not get a notepad out there's a part of
you thinks to yourself This guy's
[__] crazy he's going to get this
wrong I'm going to try I'm going to make
him yeah I want the ribs please but I
actually want them to be done with that
particular glaze and I want the tomatoes
switched out for Roma and blah blah blah
um and what he found was that while
table still had their orders open the
servers were unbelievably effective at
being able to recall what was being
ordered as soon as the tables had been
closed they had zero memory of what
they'd done so this um open loop closed
loop Dynamic that zonic found is very
fundamental to the way that our brains
work and our brains abhor an open loop
it's the same reason why think about you
know like a a missing child what is it
the parents say like we just want to
know you know they would genuinely
probably rather find out that their
child was dead than have their child
still missing after a long enough time
you know these parents that have had
kids that have been missing for 10 years
or whatever like they just it's it's
it's awful it's the same reason why uh
Cliffhangers work at the end of books or
on Netflix shows you know like you want
to know what happens next it's the
sensation of wanting to know what
happens next yeah totally the same thing
goes for the the servers as well so you
talk to me about um influence like how
does wanting influence and the
requirement of more of it play a role
here yeah so when you think about
influence and status if you had more of
it in the past for most of time still
today uh you would have a survival
Advantage right it could get you more
food it could get you out of crappy
menial labor that's just going to burn
calories it got you more mates possibly
and so I think that humans humans crave
status and influence now in the past I
don't think could influence as many
people as we could influence today
obviously right so influence has sort of
been put at scale via social media and
now what sort of one person does can
literally influence millions of people
right you can send out one tweet and if
it goes viral it could can totally
change people
um and so a lot of what that chapter in
the book looks at it's like how does how
does this really affect us and have you
ever had Jessica Tracy on I feel like
that would be someone you would have on
uh no what's what's who she she runs
this uh Lab at I think University of
Washington I'm going to kick myself
after if it's somewhere else uh that
looks at how many of our emotions uh
evolved basically just to interact with
other people uh they're totally social
emotions things like Pride shame empathy
right and a big point that she talked
about I think she has actually a book
out called pride and it just the whole
book is about Pride she looked at how
pride is this thing that basically tells
you um makes you feel good about
yourself you need to accomplish
something there's two types of Pride
there's authentic pride and hubristic
pride She lays out so authentic Pride
you feel this good feeling after you've
done something and it's great you feel
it no matter if someone sees what you've
done or not now if someone sees what
you've done great that's even better
hubis pride is different it's
essentially promoting yourself as a way
to sort of boost up your status but but
the problem is that you haven't actually
done anything so I would argue that
probably in the past it was much easier
to call out that hubristic Pride because
everyone kind of knew each other you
knew what people were doing but now you
can sort of display that on this massive
scale on social media and that can
confuse people and it can also make you
look like a jerk when people realize
that oh this person isn't actually as
great as they say yeah the weird thing
about status is that as soon as you
acknowledge that you're the game you
lose the game yeah exactly so it took it
took a long time for psychologist to
even study status for that reason
because there was it like no one wanted
I talked to this guy Cameron Anderson
who's at UC Berkeley and he he was like
yeah it took a long time for us to
really acknowledge this thing because by
acknowledging it as a psychologist
you're going oh I might you know
actually care about my status and so it
took until at least the 90s I think the
research that did it was looking at
class issues so it kind of made it more
acceptable to start studying it now
you've got this uh influx of it ah so
you're acting as this benevolent
Bourgeois sort of Ivory Tower person
speaking down from on high don't worry M
peasants the plebians I will I will
bring you up from the muck and the m and
the blood and the feces yeah that's
interesting yeah the influence things
funny man you know previously people
wanted Fame because it was a marker of
having done something worthy of being
famous now people just want to be famous
for its own sake because what Fame is is
the promise of obligation free Status at
least mod the modern conception of frame
you know you don't have to be a heroic
General you don't have to actually
invent something you can just be in the
right place at the right time and you
know reality TV is the absolute sort of
zenith of this where you get normal
people plucked out of obscurity and
placed on some television show to
be like purposefully normal like you're
you're providing average representations
of avatars within the
populace and then six weeks later they
come off and they've got 2 million
followers and a pretty little thing
contract and free charcoal toothpaste
and a blue tick and they're now
completely changed so what what is the
lesson that it teaches the modern world
about how you achieve fame and status
and influence you're in the right place
at the right time you don't do a thing
for an incredibly long amount of time
and grind hard on it what was it Thomas
Edison said I have not failed I simply
found 10,000 ways that didn't work
right right I mean even up to the Advent
of the internet if you wanted uh Fame
and attention you probably did have to
do decent things or could be opposite
you get famous for doing really bad
things but the point is that you did
something y right and so there was this
filter of of a of a large media
Corporation choosing whether or not
they're going to cover you and now you
can cover yourself if you would like and
just blast it out there and it can work
right you see a lot of people rise uh to
public like being known by many people
in the public although they haven't
necessarily really done anything that
interesting in a vacuum yeah the move
from people being judged by their deeds
to people being judged by their opinions
has meant that words carry more weight
than actions and that's a very dangerous
position to be in because you can say
things that you don't mean and you can
Proclaim things that you haven't done
yeah and and ultimately you know
performative empathy is this it's
patient zero for this and you know how
many times have we
seen it's almost to me it's almost like
the person that is the most vehement
about their empathy and standing up for
the little person and talking about the
Deeds that they've done whilst the kind
of this suspicious lack of having seen
the Deeds that they've done that's
almost a red flag for me in fact it
probably is Ellen degenerous uh lizo
right uh it's Jimmy Fallon appears to
have been popped recently for this stuff
as well all of the people that are you
know championing the little person it
turns out that lizo was body shaming her
dancers uh Jimmy Fallon the guy that's
supposed to be this bubbly super
welcoming Lefty person turns out who's a
total Tyrant Ellen degenerous as well he
someone who's supposed to be you know a
champion for different sexual
orientations and this kind of like
motherly figure late night show host and
stuff total [__] apparently allegedly
allegedly a little [__] and um yeah
it's to me the move from Deeds to
opinions has allowed people that are
prepared to lie very effectively or
obfuscate the truth or manipulate or do
self-delusion uh they've benefited more
from this than anybody else yeah yeah I
agree and I I did really find it
fascinating
how status affects us so much so one of
the one of the studies that's totally
bizarre but also very telling is that
flights that have a first class cabin
have four times greater rates of air
rage now if the passengers have to walk
through the first class cabin on their
way to the you know the where the cattle
are stored on the plane those flights
have a nine times greater rate of air
rage like that's crazy like these status
reminders they they irk people and
there's constantly status reminders we
face every day and they do seem to
affect us so the uh people who are
higher status generally have better
health outcomes in the long run and this
isn't you know you might think oh well
they can afford medical care it's like
well no because this holds even in
countries that have Universal medical
care so you would think that you know
that wouldn't hold in those countries
but it but it seems to yeah it's such a
huge determinant did you read uh will
star's book the status game I haven't
read that one now you'd love it you
would fall in love with it it's it's
absolutely fascinating so yeah this
addiction I suppose to influence that we
have and the fact that you can be
bestowed obligation free Status uh it
it's
been
objectified and U turned into a metric
game by social media right I know
exactly how many followers I know
exactly how many plays I know exactly
how many
likes so yeah that that feedback loop or
this the previous scarcity that would
have been uh I want to get more status
Downstream from status are increased
access to mates increased access to food
protection you know all that better
child mortality all this stuff uh has
been weaponized and commercialized by
Quantified Quantified to your point as
you can see exactly what it is and you
can watch that number go up on social
media that's one thing that I um talk
about in the book too is how numbers
influence us and how this rise of
gamification has in a lot of ways
shifted the goal of why we do what we do
so anytime that you put a a number on
thing and you gamify a system what tends
to happen is people start to chase
whatever the gamified number is so this
is fine in in an actual game if you're
playing football American football Chris
uh the point is to run the ball over the
into the touchdown zone right to score
these points and then you just leave the
game there and it's like okay that was
great it doesn't affect the rest of your
life but when you start to gamify um
different Tech Systems people change
their behavior so Twitter is a great
example so Twitter is theoretically
supposed to be this platform for
discussion right and then you ask okay
well what are the goals of a
discussion and the answer is like well
there's a lot of goals to discussions
right it's like to
empathize um to commiserate to share
information to sort of meet on a Level
Playing Field like oh there's all this
[__] that comes from a normal discussion
but when you go on Twitter what tends to
happen is that you see people chasing
likes retweets and follower
counts the things you need to do to
raise those metrics are usually at odds
with
discussion right so people are dicks on
Twitter because you know what happens
when you're a dick on Twitter is you get
more followers and you get more likes
and I mean they've studied this it's
like when scientists have looked at this
and you start to see when people start
to get
um likes and retweets and follower
counts and it usually tends to be from
sort of negative negative things um they
start to chase that so this happened
with uh politicians there was a group
that surveyed a bunch of I think it was
a decade's worth of tweets from
politicians in the United States and
they found that over that decade
politicians tweets got much more toxic
they use this AI algorithm to sort of
give it a tweets a toxicity score what
tended to happen in all these cases is
that you know the politician would go on
and they do normal you know what you
might think hey we're having a you know
a breakfast so and so to raise money for
the firefighters and then the minute
they would start to be more toxic that
would get more of a reaction from people
and they go oh that's it like that's how
you use this thing that's what boosts
the number so then you start chasing the
numbers the likes the retweets and that
totally changes the goal and this isn't
just in of course it's not just in
Twitter this is also Instagram you go on
to show some photos of your your friends
you know when you're out with your
friends and then people go oh wait a
minute this type of thing gets more
followers so you start to do that it's
also in uh the wine scoring world right
it's like when this Robert B Parker guy
started wine Advocate and put a number a
scoring number on bottles it totally
changed the wine making industry which
had had this same practice for 2,000
years but this guy starts this magazine
goes okay I want to make you know wine
accessible to the people I'm going to
taste all these wines and I'm going to
give them a score from 50 to 100 and
what happened is that the bottles that
had this very clear score that had a
high score they started to sell way more
and so wine makers went we make more
money if we make wines that suit this
guy's taste so they started cranking out
more bottles that this Robert B Parker
guy liked it totally shifts the industry
now if you're a person who doesn't share
taste with Robert Parker you're like
well this is meaningless to me right and
so once we start to fixate on numbers
long story short is that this changes
our behaviors and why we do what we do
I've been playing with this idea of
hidden and observable metrics over the
last few weeks so uh it's my belief that
people will often trade a hidden metric
for an observable metric and the
gamification makes this plain so a
really good hidden metric would be
something like peace of mind or sanity
and a good observable metric would be
something like salary or the amount of
money that you earn so you could quite
happily sacrifice uh how calm you feel
by taking a job where your Frontline
defense customer complaints person but
they know that this is a difficult job
so they're going to compensate you more
highly so you've gained $10,000 per year
but how much has your much more
important metric of sanity and peace of
mind degraded you know and if someone
was actually to somehow be able to give
you a sanity score you would realize
that you had netted a negative by doing
this another one might be something like
um the quality of your relationships
right uh so the quality of your
relationships with your partner uh you
take a job that's a little bit further
away uh again you're going to make a
little bit more money but it means that
you spend less time with your wife or
your children and in future the memories
that you have are not going to be so
good but you know it's it's ephemeral
it's like it's out there do you know
what I mean like [__] I can't tell
how this is working how much how many
more steps closer to to a divorce am I
today how much has my relationship
degraded and um yeah I I think that
making the hidden observable is a really
good strategy that we should be trying
to do things like journaling uh you know
things like um doing a weekly check-in
of some kind having some sort of process
to just check in okay the things that
I've said that genuinely matter that I
can't see another one from your world um
how many people have optimized the
observable metric of weight on a scale
but sacrificed the hidden metric of
Health right right I've dialed back my
body fat or I have um changed my
composition so that I'm carrying way
more muscle but the actual internal
state of where I'm at is [__] uh right
or even uh I mean think of activity
trackers right people get it because
they want to be more active and then
they get obsessed with these arbitrary
metrics that whether it's a step count
whether it's you know if you use one of
these devices that gives you some sort
of daily strin count um people get
hooked on that and it changes how they
do what they do and oftentimes why they
do what they do because you do you start
it for health but people often times
don't go okay well what does Health mean
to me so then you get this thing and
you're like well health is making sure I
get a nine on my whatever you know this
this thing that I wear that tells me a
strength count and the problem too is
that all of these trackers use these
sort of mysterious algorithms and
they're working on very flawed systems
you're making assumptions that this
device is taking perfect metrics all the
time perfect measurements you're
assuming that the people who created
this algorithm which most companies
won't share how they figure out these
numbers because it's you know
proprietary you're assuming that those
people are making the right decisions
based on data that is correct and it's I
mean it's definitely not in some degree
the question is like okay to what degree
is this this wrong right and yet we get
really hooked on these type of things
you see a lot of people do another great
example of this would be I'm a I'm a
professor and so I see it with my
students right the point of going to a
university is is what there's a ton it's
like yeah you want the degree but like
you're there to meet people you're there
to learn to be a damn adult you're there
to show up learn to show up on time
learn to turn in assignments on time
learn to interact with your peers and
have discussions and disagree with
people in a nice way but what tends to
happen with my students is they get
obsessed with
grades it's the
GPA right so that is not the same as
everything I've just listed why you go
to the university yeah that's uh good
heart's law in measure in uh in practice
right you know good heart's law yeah I
think so when a measure becomes an
outcome it ceases to be a good measure
so it's you know if you gave your
customer service um Team the
measure that you would say what what
we're looking for you to do is reduce
down the fraud rate and what the outcome
is that occurs is every customer is
treated like a fraudster so yeah you've
managed to drive the fraud rate down but
the actual felt experience that you
wanted the outcome you wanted was we
want to have a successful company with
customers that care about us that
doesn't have too much fraud what you
ended up doing was creating this
tyrannical [__] customer service
representative team uh you were talking
about food earlier on have you ever seen
those videos of uh tribal people eating
cheesecake for the first time no but I'm
going to need to see that cuz I bet it
does do they love it or do they just
absolutely hate it it blows their minds
right it absolutely blows their minds
because it's this really interesting
blend of sugar and fat it's got um
orifices design of food uh so very
rarely ancestrally would we have ever
had something that was both crunchy and
fluffy so if you think about Oreos or
french fries or cheesecake you have a
very interesting blend of textures you
know it's not just one texture even in
[__] yogurts people throw granola on
the top like why is that good well it's
good because it's this it's a a blend of
the different textures if you go full
liver King mode and just start eating
raw liver like it's not a particularly
exciting texture right is you just it's
slimy and it's kind of all one thing so
yeah I mean food when you're looking at
scarcity Loop food has to be it's got
probably the prime culprit I would guess
yeah definitely I mean just as I told
you about how there's this casino lab
trying to figure out how to you know
tweak the perfect slot machine in games
and make sure every experience that
happens in a casino leads us to the
behavior that they sort of want this is
obviously happening in the food in the
food industry right so especially around
the
1970s you start to see the rise of ultra
processor food so after especially after
World War II companies start to put a
lot of money into developing foods that
are going to just check all the boxes
you need to make a human love them and
they realize we need to uh increase
snacking as well because if you're
eating three square like we used to it's
like well they're leaving a lot of money
on the table we got to create snacking
as a thing and what we tend to snack on
is these Ultra processed foods and
there's a uh food industry exact who
explained if you want to get a snack
food to sell uh it's got to have three
V's it's got to have value it's got to
have variety it's G to have velocity
that is basically the scarcity Loop
right velocity in the food does that
mean that you throw it at someone
aggressively that means you eat it fast
ah you eat it fast so so value It's
relatively cheap uh variety there's a
wide variety of flavors right there's
unpredictability embedded in the food
like you go to the grocery store and
there's like 75 different kinds of chips
right um and when people have more
options of what to eat they tend to eat
more and then velocity is simply when
you hyper process a food we tend to eat
it
faster and there's been some interesting
research at the NIH where they will give
people a diet that is matched for you
know macros and salt and all that one of
the diets is ultra processed and the
other is minimally processed and what
tends to happen and they let them eat as
much as they want over the course of a
day and this is a this is a study where
they lock people in the lab so it's like
a twoe study you can't keep them in the
lab for too long but that allows them to
measure exactly every gram of everything
they ate and people tend to eat about
500 fewer calories a day when they're
eating minimally processed food and one
of the main reasons for that is when a
food is ultra processed we can simply
eat it
faster that's interesting so it's not
even necessarily to do with the
palatability although that'll contribute
a little bit
but you can just get it down you
presumably density as well is a good
chunk of this that yeah if you ever
looked at how many carbs are in a a
Haribo and then you compared that to how
much potato you would get to eat
compared with the Haribo it's insane
yeah so that's exactly it you're
concentrating the calories really so as
part of the book I uh I traveled into
the Bolivian Amazon there's a tribe
called the chimane who have the
healthiest Hearts ever recorded by
scientists so I fly into laaz I take
this 12-hour crazy car ride down to this
town that's a jumping off point into the
Amazon and then we take a uh it's called
a pek pek boat which is this really long
canoe that has this really annoying
motor on the back of it for six hours
and then you know it's it's just a wall
of jungle for six hours and eventually
the dude pulls the pek peky over I'm
like it's all look the same you know
he's like no this is it trust me it's
like okay so we get out of this damn
boat and like walk up and sure enough
you know there's the tribe and I stayed
with them um for a little while and so
not only do they have uh super healthy
Hearts they don't really have any
markers of Health disease of heart
disease and the reason that's important
is because heart disease is the number
one killer of people in the developed
world like by far everyone worries about
cancer no heart disease is probably
what's going to kill you you have about
a coin flip chance of dying from heart
disease uh they also don't get they
don't seem to get diseases like
Alzheimer
they don't get certain cancers so
they're this super healthy group of
people in a lot of ways now the ways
they're not healthy are problems that we
cured in the past right they get things
like pneumonia they get random
infections that we've figured out long
ago and that's what ends up killing or
they get bit by snakes things like that
but um a lot of what's kept them healthy
is it goes back to what they
eat and what they eat is kind of
interesting because at some point in a
in a day in a given day of eating food
it's going to give the middle finger to
some popular diet that we've been sold
over the last 40 years so it's not paleo
it's not vegan it's not low carb it's
not necessarily low fat it's you know
it's not any of this stuff they eat the
real
commonality of all the foods they eat is
that they have just one ingredient so
it's red meat from animals they hunt
it's a lot of fish it's white rice that
they grow it's a lot of fruit that they
grow it's it's white potatoes it's you
know just this basic stuff and you just
can't eat that much of those foods and
they also don't have a billion triggers
that push you into eating more it's like
if you ever sit down and try to your
back let's bring it back to potatoes
because that's a damn good food so if
you have a boiled potato it's probably
going to be like 150 calories if you
just sit and just eat that with like no
salt or anything holy hell that is a
task like it is really hard if you give
me like 10 times the calories in chips I
could probably get through it I mean I
could probably crush a thousand calories
in chips without and it would be a great
time right i' just be like oh man this
is a great experiment let's do this [__]
again soon and so I think that that's
really what it comes down to because
when you look at the average American
diet especially in the OR many developed
countries we're at like 60% foods that
are ultr processed and so over time you
just eat more I think than you plan to
you end up heavier and that impacts your
disas risk Okay so we've got a lot of
different ways that we get hijacked
whether it be status whether it be
influence whether it be information
certainty food how does somebody step in
and break the scarcity Loop yeah so
there's basically three ways uh the
first is just uh becoming aware of it by
becoming by observing it by observing a
behavior you tend to change it it's a
Hawthorne effect uh second is that you
can change or take out any three of the
parts so you can change the opportunity
you can change the unpredictable Rewards
or remove them and you can or you can
slow the behavior down so let's take
food as an example so with unpredictable
rewards in food a lot of the reasons why
we eat is because we have so many
different hyper palatable flavors and
options so people who eat the same thing
day in and day out they tend to weigh
less overall because it's basically
predictable you're not going to be
eating a ton when you've got 50
different options and then with uh the
speed or the quick repeatability eating
foods that are far less process lead you
just it slows down the process of eating
and you end up eating less with
something like social media you can
change the opportunity because I think
what happens as we talked about is when
people go on social media it goes from I
just want to share some photos of my dog
to oh I need to score these points and
you post and you go oh yeah I'm waiting
for these these likes to come in um you
can change why you're using it you can
be like okay look here's how I'm using
social media I'm literally using it to
keep up with my friends I'm using it to
share information about some cause I'm
only following people who are in this
Lane that I want to know more about
right uh you can slow it down and this
sounds kind of crazy because I've always
I've been skeptical when the answer to
using an app is to use another app but
there are great apps that simply put a
sort of brief period of hold before you
can open another app so you might go to
open the app this other app will go okay
you can open it in countdown and just
having that it slows down people's use
of it because you have to be intentional
you your best what's the best app of
that that you found um I think it's
called clear space I'd have to look at
the name um yeah the guys and I used the
what converted me is the guys who
founded it had seen me write about the
benefits of switching to grayscale on
your phone which changes effectively the
unpredictable rewards uh your phone just
becomes less stimulating less
rewarding and so they reached out to me
they're like yeah try our app and I was
yeah okay I'll try I didn't try it
because I'm like yeah I'm not going to
download your [__] app so I can use
another apps right but I did it my damn
screen time went way down because I had
to get intentional with when I was going
to use it and why wow um with something
like
shopping if I'm going to buy a which I'm
going to do after this buy a fce waterer
um with something like I can't believe
this thing is still alive dude like how
long do these things live I thought they
liveed like 30 minutes God been talking
for an hour and 10 minutes [__] should
be dead by
now this is so
good with shopping with
shopping you can um ask yourself why am
I am I buying this in the first place
what is the opportunity that I'm trying
to get from this item because a lot of
times I think we buy because we're bored
we're on Instagram because we're bored
and then we see this perfectly targeted
ad and we're like oh yeah maybe I could
use those shoes that seem to be
perfectly made in a lab for my style
right but you really you know need them
it's the question it's like what are you
trying to get out of this a lot of times
it goes back to I'm bored I think it's
going to raise my status to have this
item I think it's going to help me
belong to a group I think it's going to
do all the different things and so even
just inserting the question helps um you
can slow that down as well if you just
say anytime I see something online I'm
GNA wait x amount of days to buy it now
when I've done that I'll put something
in my cart or I'll just you know go oh
yeah it's that item within three to four
or five days I'm like what was that
thing I wanted to buy oh yeah why do I
want to buy that I don't really need
that right yeah so I think just learning
that we're in this world now where we
have just an abundance of all these
things that we're built to Crave and we
have all these systems that can really
push us into these decisions very
quickly and that's really changed our
behavior and so trying to unpack the
mechanics of that system that Loop and
then find ways to break it down I think
can be beneficial for people in changing
Behavior [__] yeah man it's it's so
strange to think about how mismatched we
are and it does feel like a a
imbalanced battlefield that we're on as
at the moment uh you know there was
there was especially when it comes to
information and and sort of stimulus
there was one day in probably early 2011
when there was the right balance between
how much information we wanted and how
much information we were getting and
then very very quickly it went from
being below to just and it completely
blasted through and you know in the
past especially when it comes to
information
you're the best skill set that you
needed was that of a a scout whereas the
best skill set that you could have now
is that of a discerner right it's
somebody that is able to kind of cut
through and weave and know when that's
enough and so on and so forth and the
same thing the moderation for everything
if that you have grown up and evolved
with a predisposition to get more and
now there is more than you need like
what do you think's going to happen like
you're going to end up you're going to
end up overloading on absolutely
everything and yeah is it Aristotle he
talks about the golden mean it's not a
viice of excess nor aice of uh scarcity
or something like that um yeah man it's
tough I'm glad that you are putting your
hand to a problem that everybody is
super familiar with and I'm a big fan of
your substack as well I'm glad that
you've joined us here on the uh
independent Creator muuk and Maya cesp
too yeah man it's been a fun uh project
for people who are interested it's uh 2%
but the website is tww pct.com it's been
a fun project man I mean I didn't know
how it would go the the reception has
been better than I expected which is
awesome um and I get a lot of I have a
lot of fun doing it which I think is
really key I can explore things that I
otherwise wouldn't have were I writing
for a lot of the magazines that I used
to write for right things get edited
down to the bone there's stuff where
you're like this is the most fascinating
part of this and it gets taken out so I
really dive into I think the stuff that
is most uh useful and there's not as
many uh constraints sometimes I might
need some constraints on word counts
because I'll send out an email every now
and then where I'm like how the hell is
this 2500 words what are you doing man
um but all the information I like and
people seem to like it so hell yeah
Michael Easter ladies and gentlemen
what's the book Michael where should
people go the book is called scarcity
brain it's uh available
anywhere that anywhere anywhere will be
where people get it dude I appreciate
you I'm looking forward to seeing what
you do next if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe